Hey 42 here do you know what you're
reading I mean do you really know
because you may think you do but you'd
be lied to your entire life now this may
be hard to stomach but a lot of the food
you eat is fake okay this is not true
for everyone watching
different countries have vastly
different food regulations and some
countries are far far worse offenders
it's dishing of fake food to its
citizens I reveal the worst countries
for doing this in a minute but first
let's take a jar of harmless honey
it started as one of nature's superfoods
it can prevent cancer heart disease it's
a powerful probiotic and it boosts your
immune system and all of that is true
if you're eating actual honey that is
Germany is the world's largest importer
of honey those Germans just love their
honey but the world's second largest
importer of honey America tells a very
different story when it comes to this
supposedly holy natural products a study
found that over 75% of pudding sold in
the US doesn't contain any honey
according to the FDA honey has to
contain pollen otherwise it just isn't
honey it was discovered that the vast
majority of commercial honey brown on
the shelves and American stores
contained no pollen at all and therefore
were not actually funny so if all this
honey isn't honey then what is it
well there are many different carefully
engineered cocktails of artificial
ingredients that are used to replicate
real honey and each producer uses their
own unique mixture most are mainly made
up from the infamous high fructose corn
syrup sometimes labeled as multi loss
syrup which is cut with sucrose syrup
and water sometimes some plant extracts
and essential oils are thrown in there
if you're looking so you thought you
were being healthy by swapping your
pancake syrup for honey put in reality
it's probably the exact same
so why do American honey producers sell
billions of dollars worth of artificial
sugars labeled as honey simple economics
real honey is expensive just think about
what has to happen to make honey bees
have to visit two million flowers to
produce just one quart of honey
traveling fifty five thousand miles in
the process and over its entire lifetime
a single bit will produce just half a
teaspoon of honey high fructose corn
syrup and other similar ingredients are
incredibly cheaper to produce and so
companies can sell fake honey for much
much cheaper to consumers who are none
the wiser there are also no regulations
in place in America concerning the
actual percentage of real funny content
required in Europe there are very very
strict rules about what can be labeled
and sold as honey
EU regulation stipulates that anything
souls as honey must contain more than
60% actual honey seems fair enough and
they cannot contain more than 5 percent
sucrose ie syrup the vast majority of
honey sold across Europe was found to be
100% pudding also through no fault of
their own Americans are not used to the
idea that fully crystallizes very
quickly and 100% raw honey will usually
already be highly crystallized when you
take it off the shelf what honey
never spoils and crystallization is
completely normal after all it is a
sugar and sugar just love to crystalize
europeans have always been sold
crystallized honey and so are used to
the idea a survey found that most
Americans would wrongly consider
crystallized honey to be spoiled but
when you're selling syrups
disguised as honey you don't have to
worry about crystallization 2.3 billion
cups of coffee are drank every day
around
world but what goes into your let
me guess
ground coffee or instant coffee if
you're an animal
hot water then maybe milk or cream and
perhaps some sugar oh and of course
let's not forget the wheat soybean seeds
corn twigs and dirt yes you heard me
correctly your ground coffee which
should just be coffee right actually
contains a whole array of fillers and
more often than not these fillers
contain twigs and dirt well you did say
you like your copies with an earthy
flavor Coffee is in trouble big trouble
Coffee is very sensitive it doesn't like
being called names but it's also very
picky about where it's grown the plant
will only produce coffee seeds known to
us all as coffee beans in humid and very
altitude earnest mountainous areas
according to several expert climate
change is threatening these sensitive
environments and forecasts show that by
half of the regions in the world where
coffee can be grown will be lost forever
and by 2080 coffee could go extinct due
to these growing fears some unscrupulous
ground coffee manufacturers have
resorted to padding out their happy
using fillers such as soy beans brown
sugar barley and corn some byproducts of
coffee production that should really be
removed from the final product are also
purposely being left in to fill it out
such as wood twigs parchment husks and
even soil if you buy whole beams then
don't worry there won't be any fillers
in that Brazilian scientists were so
concerned about this that they developed
a brand new technique using liquid
chromatography and statistical analysis
that allows them to detect exactly what
percentage of a bag of ground coffee is
actual coffee
the procedure is 95%
and what they discovered was that some
grams or ground coffee has such a high
percentage of fillers in them but they
must be purposely added in there's just
no way it's an accident if coffee isn't
your thing then maybe orange juice is
you may have been told many times that
most diamonds juices are artificial but
do you really know just how artificial
what if I told you that the flavor of
most major orange juice brand is 100%
fake to make orange juice you just
squeeze oranges right maybe throw in
some preservatives and added sugar no
that would just be too simple for big
brand orange juices they squeeze their
own jizz and then they remove all of the
oxygen from the extracted juice this
allowed to juice to keep for a year
without spoiling yes your morning juice
is anywhere from a few months to a year
old but that's not all that removing the
oxygen doors it also removes all of the
natural flavor and I mean all of it
so they're left to have a very old
completely tasteless liquid that
slightly resembles something that came
out of an orange wants the orange flavor
is then artificially re added to the
juice using a concoction of artificial
flavorings
but why purposely remove the flavor and
then put it back in again if it only
makes it worse
I mean that's not easy or cheap to do
well it's all about consistency each big
brand orange juice has their own unique
flavor that their customers are all very
familiar with just imagine if the taste
of Tropicana changed slightly millions
of people would notice and kick up a big
still article the natural flavor from
oranges is just not consistent and not
to stick a brand name on it and have
people associate that flavor with that
particular brand because the flavor
would constantly change depending on the
variety of the orange location of the
oranges and this high
year our industries manufactures than
millions hiring flavor and fragrance
experts the very same people that work
for large perfume companies to create
our unique and recognizable orange juice
like flavor for that product they call
these flavor packs and the worst part is
that the flavorings don't even have to
be listed under the ingredients because
they're derived from orange oils which
is a dubious claim but it technically
means that these artificially flavored
drinks can be sold as 100% orange juice
so that's orange juice I bet you're
wondering which of your favorite foods
I'm going to ruin next what about a
simple steak no not the steak a steak is
just a single cut of beef right what
could possibly be suspicious about that
well if you opt for cheaper steaks
whether it be from the supermarket or
even your local butcher you could be
eating tens of different cuttle in a
single steak you're purchasing
Frankenstein steaks that have actually
been glued together from a whole array
of off corns and this doesn't just
happen with beef it could be lamb pork
venison or any meat really when many
animals are being turned into various
types of small food products ready to
throw into a pan at home also the waste
is created and general chunks of meat
that would most likely get thrown away
some unscrupulous companies and butchers
use a meat glue called trans luta man
eggs which is well known within the food
industry and is completely untraceable
within the final product they basically
glue together the leftover pieces which
could have come from many different cows
to create one big Frankenstein's sake
for your enjoyment transglutaminase is
so good at fusing these together it
would take an expert to examine a snake
very closely to detect any wrongdoing
the best part it's not a legal
requirement to list it of ingredients so
to be safe to stay away from cheap steak
but what is you already do maybe you are
a cow connoisseur who ops to spend 40 50
or even $100 plus on a single steak in a
restaurant and your favorite steak of
all is of course a very pricey
Kobe beef the Kobe beef craze has taken
America in particular by storm thousands
of restaurants all over the country and
many large chains now offer highly
prized and highly prized Kobe beef
burgers Kobe steaks and other Kobe beef
products on their menus Kobe beef comes
from Kobe cows a breeded Wagyu beef that
comes from Japan the steaks they produce
are pride by chefs all over the world
for that impressive fat marbling flavor
and that melt-in-your-mouth texture it
is the ultimate steak but it's
incredibly exclusive Kobe B you can only
come from Japan and just 3,000 cattle
are deemed worthy enough to be
slaughtered and turned into Kobe beef
each year they are all fathered by just
12 highly prized bulls that are
considered genetically ideal sounds to
me like they're trying to create a cow
master race over there
Kobe cows are fed beer and sake to
improve flavor and every cow is massaged
daily to improve its fat marbling hell I
want to be a Kobe cow now that is some
serious dedication to creating a tasty
steak it doesn't come cheap it varies
but it will cost you on average about
three hundred and fifty dollars to eat a
real Kobe steak in a restaurant because
supplies are purposely kept small to
focus on quality the amount of real Kobe
beef that reaches the u.s. each year
would only feed 77 Americans and yet
millions of Americans are going out and
regularly eating Kobe beef in
restaurants
and buying it from the shop to cook at
home for far far less than three hundred
and fifty dollars per steak so what's
going on here it is one of the biggest
food scams in America's history as you
have probably guessed by now the vast
vast majority of so-called Kobe beef
sold in America is just plain old
regular beef that has never even been to
Japan it's just outright lying and
clever marketing if you can call it
clever some farms in America are even
now creating fake Kobe beef for much
cheaper often called Kobe beef by those
in the know this fake Kobe is sold to
thousands of restaurants and customers
pay upwards of $100 of steak for it but
in reality there are only nine
restaurants in the whole of America that
sells real Kobe beef imported from Japan
yes just nine and they have a special
license allowing them to cook and sell
it the faith food that you consume in
the average day is sickening your olive
oil is actually peanut oil soya bean oil
and palm oil your cheese and even bread
contains water pool yes wood pulp which
the FDA says is safe to eat thanks for
the advice but last time I checked I
wasn't a beaver your dried spices and
herbs contain a large amount of garden
weeds your tea contains sawdust and some
yummy yummy yummy blueberries are also
often faith most product containing
blueberries such as muffin cereals and
pancakes contain precisely 0 blueberries
real blueberries are expensive and so
food scientists have perfected a recipe
of sugar purple dye and other
questionable ingredients to craft
imitation blueberries that have no
health benefits whatsoever in America
most of the champagne sold is not
actually champagne most people believe
that it's illegal to sell
sparkling wine has champagne if it
doesn't originate from the champagne
province in France and this is produced
using the method shunkan wants a second
fermentation within the bottle well yes
this is true in every country in the
world except America a 100 year old
legal loophole allows any American
sparkling wine a simple bottle of
Californian bubbly for example which may
be nice to be sold as champagne which it
isn't with in America do this in any
other country and French lawsuits will
take your fake champers off of the
shelves faster than you can say is this
the bloody French Inquisition or what of
course all of this changes depending on
where you live in the world every
country has its own unique food
regulations and different levels of food
quality what which countries have the
most fake food and which have the least
British charity Oxfam conducted a study
comparing the quality of food in every
country in the world the best countries
in the world overall for food quality
and lack of food related health issues
were found to be the Netherlands France
Switzerland Denmark and Sweden well done
guys but shockingly at the other end of
the spectrum was America for quality and
health related food issues the USA
ranked a hundred and twentieth out of
125 countries putting it in the same
league as Saudi Arabia Jordan Ethiopia
and Chad
it's one of life's great ironies that
the world's wealthiest superpower some
of the lowest quality food in the world
but it's not the fault of the American
people large American food companies
that have monopolized the market use
every trick in the book
and some horrifying techniques and
chemicals to make terribly poor quality
food seem more appealing to shoppers and
in America and some other countries the
regulations just
arms in place you properly regulate what
goes into people's food at least they're
nowhere near stringent or not we'll just
remember every time you shop you are
voting avoiding cheap processed and
general dodgy looking food will reduce
the demand for it choosing to instead
shop at local stores with real high
quality food will make a difference and
you'll live a longer and happier life
for it as well just for the sake of a
bit less convenience you wouldn't eat
garbage out of the bed so don't settle
for buying it off the shelves thanks for
watching if there's some reason you
actually enjoy my videos then click here
to support me on patreon supporting me
helps me to make better videos and you
can get some pretty cool rewards as well
click here to check out another video
and if you haven't already don't forget
to subscribe for new videos every week